dans les années 90 cité paru sur le
marché un produit sans viande le végé
pâté qui depuis séduit les végétariens
mais aussi les carnivores un substitut
au pâté de viande et au terrine qu'on
choisit pour ces valeurs nutritives mais
ce qu'on fait en compromis sur le goût
on teste aujourd'hui 4 produits le bio
bon le fontaine santé le gusta et le
pote de l'UQAM place à la dégustation
sachez que ces quatre produits québécois
qu'on trouve facilement en épicerie
est-ce que vous en consommez déjà
un pâté fait d'aliments végétaux et vous
capable de déceler qu'est-ce qu'il y a
comme ingrédient là-dedans
c'est super facile à faire maison
normalement ce qu'on trouve là-dedans
c'est par exemple des légumes comme des
pommes de terre des patates douces des
carottes des oignons on retrouve des
graines de tournesol d'à peu près tous
les végétats puis aussi la levure
alimentaire qui donne un goût qui
contribue aussi à la valeur nutritive il
y en a qui ont du tofu il y en a qui ont
des lentilles et puis après ça les
assaisonnements ou les additifs ça
encore ça va être le secret du fabricant
en général
des trucs en France mais avec de la
viande du coup les végétatif pour
certains ont voulu imiter des parties de
viande et d'autres c'est complètement
différent
et ça on peut le mettre sur du pain
certains végétaux vont être des supers
garnitures à sandwich donc vont mieux se
tartiner sur des craquelins par exemple
contrairement à ce que l'on peut penser
il y a pas beaucoup de protéines dans
les végétats même si ce sont des graines
de tournesol qui en contiennent un peu
c'est tellement mélangé à d'autres
ingrédients qu'au final la quantité de
végétarité qu'on va mettre dans un
sandwich n'est pas suffisante pour
rendre notre sandwich vraiment
rassasiant ça va prendre d'autres
ingrédients ça va prendre un lunch un
peu plus soutenant
êtes-vous amateur de végé Pathé non mais
je veux découvrir ça
[Musique]
je sens le goût de la carotte que j'aime
le plus le végétatif de Fontaine santé
le premier ingrédient c'est les graines
de tournesol puis on voit un peu à la
couleur le côté beige de ce végét Pathé
il y a des pommes de terre aussi il y a
des carottes il y a différents légumes
il y a des oignons aussi dans cette
liste d'ingrédients là c'est vraiment un
peu comme une recette maison où il y a
pas d'additifs il y a rien de superflu
là à mon oeil de nutritionniste ou du
végé
celui-là probablement
à étendre lui
préférer
ça peut se retrouver dans le lunch dans
de vos enfants
bon
c'est plus frais
le premier ingrédient du bio bon c'est
les pommes de terre les graines de
tournesol arrivent quand même pas très
loin derrière je trouve que ça ressemble
quand même à une recette maison si tu as
un des végétariens les plus riches en
matière grasse de notre échantillon
c'est quand même pas négligeable par
exemple à côté du fontaine de santé
c'est presque le double c'est pas
excessif c'est correct je pense qu'il
faut juste peut-être le mentionner vu
que l'on fait la comparaison mais c'est
pas alarmant
avec le fait que c'est un peu granuleux
à du foie gras non
on voit une couleur un peu rosée je
pense que c'est lui qui veut imiter le
pâté de foie les premiers ingrédients
c'est de l'eau et de l'huile mais sinon
on va aussi les lentilles la liste
d'ingrédients si ça commence par de
l'eau ou de l'huile mode d'un point de
vue nutritionnel ou même qualité de
l'aliment je trouve ça un petit peu
moins intéressant la fermeté vient
peut-être aussi du fait qu'il y a de
l'huile de noix de coco là dedans c'est
un peu plus saturé comme gras
tombe on pourrait penser que ça goûte un
petit peu le porc donc ça se rapproche
plus de la viande que les trois autres
très bon aussi plus onctueux à tartiner
je pense je préférais celui qui plus
lisse mais dans un sandwich je pense je
préférais celui avec la texture
préféré le porate le premier ingrédient
c'est de l'eau donc on le voit à son
aspect très liquide vraiment il y a de
la misère à cette année et aussi du tofu
et ça aussi on le voit on le voit
vraiment dans la texture les petits
morceaux de tofu broyé grâce à son tofu
c'est notre végétatif qui a plus que le
plus de protéines je peux pas dire que
c'est une bonne source de protéines mais
tout est en relatif il y en a un petit
peu plus que les autres il y a quand
même une liste d'ingrédients assez
longue c'est le seul dans cet
échantillon qui a des additifs
alimentaires ça c'est plus mou
je trouve ça me fait penser à du mieux
on dirait presque toujours
qui consomme des végétaux très surprise
je pensais que ça allait être dans les
habitudes alimentaires de nos bouteilles
alors les résultats récolté 8 votes le
bio bon 11 et dans les gagnants presque
exéco le porate et le fontaine de santé
merci à tous
[Musique]